Зазвичай цими полями на Чернігівщині після зимової відлиги не проїхати.
Та цього року замість багнюки - курява.
Валентин Шкітюк, аграрій з 30-річним досвідом, такої аномальної весни не пам'ятає.
По дорозі їдеш - і таке відчуття, що вже жнива. Не посівна, а жнива.
Завжди у нас жнива такі.
Пилові бурі йдуть. А цього року весна почалася з цього. Поки що не радує.
Аби врятувати свій майбутній врожай Валентину Шкітюку
цього року довелося змінити технологію посіву.
Сівалки переобладнав під рідкі добрива, на це витратив півмільйона гривень.
Тепер у перші тижні після висіву зерно матиме поживу.
Але якщо дощу і далі не буде - цілорічний заробіток фермера під загрозою.
Аномально тепла зима та посушлива весна - не єдина тривога українських аграріїв.
Неочікувані зміни приніс селу коронавірус. Тепер доводиться зважати на заходи безпеки.
У компанії Agricom Group підприємця Петра Мельника
яка на 50 відсотків залежить від експорту,
вже відчули коливання європейського ринку у зв'язку з коронавірусом:
поки одні більш заможні країни, як-от Голландія, збільшують замовлення,
інші - бідніші на кшталт Румунії,
у зв'язку з кризою вже просять відтермінувати оплату на шість місяців.
Та, головне, каже, у часи пандемії зберегти робітників.
Самий гірший сон для нас зараз, щоб ніхто не захворів, тому що тоді
той ризик, що треба буде ізолювати частину людських ресурсів -
це може призвести до колапсу якогось.
Маючи ТМЦ, у нас не буде це ким сіяти і ким обробляти.
Валентин Шкітюк та Петро Мельник - бізнеспартнери.
Значну частину зернових Шкітюк продає переробному заводу Мельника.
Тож, для фермерів і біди спільні.
Місяць йому нормально буде, більш-менш,
якщо дощі не підуть, треба бубни брати, маски одягати і шаманити.
І шаманити, дощі закликати.
Це просто зараз ризик значний, він набагто суттєвіший для нас аграріїв, ніж коронавірус.
Місяць мати вологу - це як в казіно зайти.
Тут, на дев'ятистах гектарах землі, яка належить чернігівським пайовикам,
фермери переймаються і прийнятим у ніч з 30 на 31 березня законом про ринок землі.
Вони підтримують наміри влади повернути селянам право розпоряджатися власною землею.
З іншого боку, у селян є побоювання, що в період економічної кризи,
пов'язаної з коронавірусом, землю скуплять олігархи.
До того ж, рік тому, згідно з нормативно-грошовою оцінкою земельних ділянок,
чернігівська земля не зросла, а навіть впала в ціні.
У думках навіть не було продавати землю,
так як в минулому році паї на території Кархівського старостинського округу
коштував 86-87 тисяч, а тепер 25-26 тисяч, виходить, зменшили нормативно-грошову оцінку.
Такий закон прийняли наші депутати Верховної Ради.
Та й за такої низької ціни українські фермери навряд чи спроможні її придбати.
Тут буде дві категорії: в кого є гроші не лише від сільського господраства,
а інші доходи - той буде купувати, а хто займається лише сільським господарством,
той багато не накупляє. Я так скажу на сьогоднішній день.
Вигідніше оренду кожен рік платити,
ніж витратити мільйони, десятки мільйонів доларів треба на покупку.
Пайовики чернігівського села Кархівки отримують до семи тисяч гривень за пай на рік.
Це невеликі гроші та, кажуть, все одно краще, ніж продати.
Не влаштовує, це дуже мало, але що ж ти зробиш...
Ми знаємо, що наша земля обробляється, якось обробляється, вже хоч якось і добрива вносять.
У селі не раді закону про ринок землі і бояться, що за умови нереформованих судів
та правоохоронних органів почнеться земельне рейдерство.
Думаю, що це не нормально, її ніхто ніколи не продавав, була земля, оралася.
Хто таке придумав! Мабуть, уже нічого продати, так ось і землю.
Залишалсь земля, а потім і Україну.
Ваучери колись були, і що? Куди пішли?
Шуфричам і Онуфричам! І вони заводи зараз мають! І тут так само!
Рейдерство почнеться, приїдуть, скажуть, давай продавай, і все. Таке воно й буде.
Ви боїтесь, що будуть скуповувати землю?
Вони вже відкрито кажуть, що будуть скуповувати!
До дискусії сусідів долучається і місцевий поет Микола Фурс.
Це ж треба так народ не поважати
Щоб Україну пхати у ярмо,
За безцінь рідну землю продавати.
Щоб конкурентів вибороть кермо...
Йому болить, що в Європі земля в рази дорожча, ніж український чорнозем.
Треба продавати, але треба мінімальну ціну ставити за гектар.
Як у Німеччині, Голандії, Польщі.
У них гектар піску коштує 25 тисяч доларів, а у нас чорнозем по 27 тисяч гривень.
Згідно із законом про ринок землі, з липня 2021 року
купувати землю зможуть тільки фізичні особи, які є громадянами України.
Максимальний розмір - сто гектарів на людину.
З 2024 року - юридичні особи з українською структурою власності,
територіальні громади та держава.
Максимальний розмір в одні руки - десять тисяч гектарів.
Іноземців на ринок допустять лише після всеукраїнського референдуму.
Такі обмеження експерти оцінюють негативно.
Бо це й буде стримувати зростання ціни на українську землю.
Якщо ми говоримо про цей ринок з економічної точки зору,
то такі обмеження не є виправданими, бо вони суттєво обмежують ринковий попит.
Відповідно ціна на землю не буде зростати так, як вона могла б зростати.
І це не є в інтересах українських землевласників.
Якщо виходити з позиції "не нашкодь", то можна вітати ухвалення цього законопроєкту, безумовно.
Але якщо говорити про земельну реформу, то можна констатувати, що вона не відбулася.
Відбулося зняття мораторію, але умови, щоб люди могли скористатися цією новою можливістю,
не були прописані.
Це, безумовно, крок уперед, але до запуску ринку це ще дуже далеко.
Чернігівські фермери з місцевими пайовиками мають контракти на оренду землі до 2025 року.
Якщо хтось і захоче протягом цього часу продати землю,
то, згідно з законом, орендарі мають право першими її викупити.
Втім, наразі накопичений капітал притримають не для купівлі землі,
а для подолання викликів, пов'язаних з коронавірусом
та цілком імовірним неврожаєм з огляду на посуху.